if some lenders had their way you do all
your shopping on a credit card
why because it makes them money lots of
it and to try to entice you to keep
spending they offer rewards some really
but are those rewards really worth it
who's being rewarded you or your bank if
you're careful airline hotel and credit
card points can get you far and some
people spend a tremendous amount of time
seeing exactly how far that is this is
Brad and he's a bit of a let's call him
a credit card connoisseur I decided to
head down to Murray Hill to check out
his massive card collection this is a
lot of credit cards walk me through how
many are here there's about 70 or 80
here how many of these are open I think
there's about 20 to 25 that are open
right now okay so like how did you get
into it like how did that process begin
and I got a letter in the mail saying
you can get there's like fifty thousand
Delta points okay for spending three
thousand dollars and three months okay
there's no fee in the first year yeah
I've got those I always toss those yeah
well you should read them because
sometimes you can see that there's no
fee and you're gonna spend that $3,000
and three months yeah if you're doing
that anyway it's free points do you know
how many points you feel like
accumulated over the last five years
yeah it's uh what is it it's probably
between like seven and ten million
points are you joking no how much time
do you spend on this on just this it's
probably a couple hours a week a
spreadsheet that I maintain and there's
like websites
it'll keep track of your loyalty
accounts but also there's kind of
research that I'm doing
the best general card anyone can get is
just 2% cash back no annual fee okay at
the end of the year you get a check in
the mail it's just free money it's it's
what you can get and you don't have to
think about it at all it seems like kind
of exhausting to someone else it would
seem like homework but I kind of enjoy
it if someone wants to get into it what
would you tell them like what's that
what's the way to start out well the
very first thing I tell them is just
make sure your finances are in order
don't carry a balance don't pay
unnecessary interest so don't ever carry
a balance no that's that's you're paying
interest on any balance that you're
carrying right that's that's money or
you're giving away treat it like a debit
card okay it's it's money that you're
you're spending each month and you pay
it off immediately okay
managing 25 open cards can be exhausting
done right like bread you can get a lot
of free stuff but it's also full of
traps that could expose you to expensive
fees
remember banks are in the business of
making money and credit cards are one of
their most profitable activities here
tell us more about how banks usually win
is Bloomberg reporter Jenny serene so
credit card companies their ideal goal
is that you'll spend each month and then
you'll pay off your bills
[Music]
or ideally actually you'll carry a
balance and they can charge you that
interest when you're thinking about
getting a credit card and using a credit
card interest is one of the most
important things to be paying attention
to for instance let's say you buy a TV
for $1,000 even if you pay off 999
dollars that bill you could still be
charged interest on the whole thing even
if you've only left a dollar on your
balance and then of course sometimes
come with the highest forms of interest
so if you're thinking about going and
chasing after crazy credit card rewards
you have to be really responsible and
stay on top of your payments if you're
very responsible and meticulously
organized like Brad then you're probably
set if it's something where you're gonna
be carrying about
how it legit walk away so yeah chasing
points requires a lot of time and care
just look at Brad as the old saying goes
make sure the juice is worth the squeeze
[Music]
you